Last time I was talking to you about the the world of Homer from the side of you
might say the life of the mind rather than the practical matters of society.
Talking about values and ethics in the world of Homer and I spoke to you.
About the heroic ethic which is excuse me the dominant element in this system of
theirs.
Another way of looking at it is that it is an aristocratic way of thinking and
feeling at the core of it is the concept of a red Tay A.R.
E.T..
Now that's a word that causes us some problems because it comes to mean in.
Even in antiquity it comes to mean something quite different and especially if
you're talking about Christianity which adopts the word as well when it comes to
mean goodness goodness in a kind of a Christian sense will erase all of those
ideas from your head when you think about the world of Homer and I would say the
world of Greece in the period we're studying at our state derives from the Greek
word on there which means man man as opposed to woman.
These are the masculine qualities as the Greeks saw them and primary among them
was the idea of courage.
Physical courage moral courage mental courage many mainly courage in battle is
the most core.
Aspect of this word this idea which comes to spread and to be much more
encompassing than that.
The idea I guess the most neutral way to translate the word is excellence
prowess the ability to do something or to be something which is admired in the
fullest way possible.
Some of the desired qualities some of the examples of outright they are.
Courage as I've said.
But also beauty
strength the ability to perform athletics very well but also to speak very well.
And it is one of the extraordinary things I think for modern people to see.
There are really two central heroes in the poems of Homer Achilles the great
central figure of the Iliad who represents physical courage strength power
beauty speed all of those things Odysseus and the hare of the Odyssey but
present and very important in both poems.
He also got all of these things but the thing that sets him apart that makes him
the special kind of hero he is is his skill in speech which doesn't mean only
that he pronounces words very well or that he selects them very well for beauty
or something but rather that he is enormously clever.
That he can use speech to achieve practical ends just as he uses strength and
power and all those other things.
And the Greeks regard in the Homer's world seem to regard one just about as well
as they do the other.
Odysseus is the man the wily Odysseus as Homer calls him the man of many devices
all of those things are are great.
And they are equally honored along with the physical courage that is so
characteristic of these guys
and
the recognition of that those qualities the recognition of the red tie that
these heroes have is what their lives are all about.
First of all they have to have these qualities.
It's not enough.
They must be recognized by the people among whom they lived by the communities
in which they live and the highest.
Rewards that individuals can have is the recognition of their fellow men of
their very very high qualities.
We are talking about.
A society therefore.
The anthropologists have come up with I think a useful distinction.
Societies based on shame as opposed to those that practice guilt guilt is
something very internal and personal shame is something very external and public
and how you are treated and greeted
is what makes your worth and so it is from the beginning.
A society in which the community is a critical element may be the critical
element an individual who didn't live in a society could not achieve the kinds
of glory and fame and recognition that you expect from a hero.
And all of these heroes are aristocrats in the traditional sense of the word.
They arrive at their high standing in their community by virtue of birth.
You are born to be one of these people because your father was such a person
belonging to the right families and so on to noble families of Greece.
And we see it already in Homer typically claim descent from some god or other.
And ordinary people do not have that ability.
The family and the individual are the critical elements a larger community
meaning your entire village or entire city your entire region that is barely
mentioned.
That is not talked about again.
Think about Achilles when he refuses to do what he is supposed to wear.
But he has to fight with the Greeks because he's had to fight with Agamemnon.
Nobody says wait a minute.
That's treason.
You can't do that.
You've been signed up by your city or by this expedition to fight and you've got
to fight.
Nobody says that what they say is Oh please we need you Achilles you mustn't do
this.
But nobody says Arrest that man.
He has broken his debt.
He's not performing his debt to the community.
Everybody knows.
All those heroes are there because they want to be and they want to be there so
that they can earn both the.
Wealth that can be taken from a defeated city.
But even more important the kind of fame and glory that comes with such deeds
and you are it.
I've already told you the story about Achilles having the choice of living
forever without fame or dying with fame and he makes the choice for death and
fame.
That I think is very critical.
That attitude that point of view even after the world of Homer is gone.
He remains a very powerful influence on the Greeks throughout the rest of their
history.
So that you have built into that society an inherent conflict.
After all even these heroes need communities in which to live for all the
various purposes that human beings do.
So you would think they have to have some allegiance to them.
They do.
But they also have an allegiance to their families and to themselves.
Which in Homer tend to predominate.
And yet there is a sense in which the conflict is very real.
If you look at the problem in Homer
Achilles when he withdraws and refuses to fight for the Army nobody can tell him
to do otherwise.
He has a right to do that but that means that something is wrong and it's very
clear that he has been overcome by rage and he is not behaving in the sensible
way that even a Greek hero is supposed to.
And he is not brought back to normal to a position in which people can say yes
well you're a great hero and you're not out of your mind because when that
happens when he gives up his rage and he allows you remember Prime to bury his
son Hector something he would have refused to do in his rage.
So that even a killings has got to come to terms with the community norms in
order to be living in a proper life.
And this conflict between his family and private desires and needs and those of
the community will be characteristic very strongly of the Greek way of life for
the rest of its history not always in precisely this same form but it will be
their competition again is rearing its head.
It's another form of competition the competition between these two sources of
value.
The community at large versus the individual and the family and this kind of
tension which doesn't make it clear the rules are not absolute.
Not everybody fits into a pigeon hole.
It is not easy to say what is the right thing.
What is the wrong thing.
All of that creates confusion problems but also amnio conflict tension
competition all those things.
But it also creates a degree of freedom which doesn't permit the typical
despotic kind of culture which characterizes almost all of the human experiences
that we know in the early history of the human race.
So there is I want to turn now to the way in which this way of thinking had an
impact on the future.
And of course I'm speaking about the future of the of Western civilization which
was the heir to this tradition.
I mentioned to you already last time that in a way the poems are a kind of a
Bible.
It is the source of all knowledge and wisdom that anybody who knows anything
knows and and how they were used for practical purposes as when the Spartans
made a decision about who owns Salloum is based on what it said in the Iliad.
But it's also important to realize how those poems inspired the imagination of
Greeks for the rest of their history.
Another fact is that we are told that when Alexander the Great went out to
conquer the Persian Empire and as far as he was concerned to conquer everything
he could reach.
He carried with him.
A copy of The Iliad which it is alleged he put under his pillow.
This is a problem when you consider that books in those days were not likely to
be Codex as courtesies as they are today but scrolls that took up quite a lot of
space.
I don't know quite how Alex managed it but that's what they say.
But the principle is established it was clear he was another Achilles in his own
eyes and it was for him to achieve the great deeds that I have been mentioning
now.
If you look at the story of Western civilization it provides a very interesting
contrast within it and the I'm sorry the Greek experience that I'm talking about
now based upon what you see in Homer provides a contrast with and a competition
to the other great tradition of Western civilization which is the
Judeo-Christian tradition.
And I just want to make a few small points to indicate how that works
the Iliad begins.
The first word in the Iliad is the accusative now Main in its wrath anger I am
singing about the wrath the anger of Achilles which brought so many men to their
doom is what Homer says the first thing is the emotion of an individual man.
The odyssey begins even more strikingly with the word undrawn.
The accusative on there the the accusative case of a man and he says Sing to me
God is about that man.
That man of many devices that that clever man Odysseus the need of Virgil based
of course on the Iliad The Odyssey begins Armagh we room Kwa Colonel I sing of
arms and the man.
The man in is now that's what did the Greeks took talking about.
I'm talking about individual men extraordinary men and the events that emerge
from them and the life they lead.
Well let's look at our Bible begins this will be news to most of you
in the beginning God created the heavens and the earth and it the book goes
right on to talk about God.
What he does sometimes why he does it.
What is the effect of what he does.
But the center of our.
Book is God not man.
And there's some that there's not just an accident that reveals the
characteristic of each one of these cultures.
The Greeks had a humanistic outlook on life.
They believed in the gods.
They were religious people.
But the core of their lives was shaped by things human in a way different from
what was true of the Hebrews and the Christians later on
versus a divine view.
The secular approach is very very Greek versus a religious approach the Greek
view.
Moreover.
Presupposes that man lives in society.
He is not a creature off by himself by definition.
He necessarily lives in society.
He is conceivable to the Greeks only in a society the Iliad which is about a
war.
Immediately is a kind of an artificial society put together for the purpose of
defeating the Trojans and taking their city.
As I've said suggested to you the values that are the most important are
community values.
That is to say the reward of good behavior is the admiration and the honor that
a hero gets and the most serious punishment he can suffer is to be shamed in
front of that community Aristotle late writing late in the Greek tradition but
still powerfully influenced by these kinds of ideas speaks about man as a Greek
words are a political zone and I think the best way to understand that is to
think of it as meaning man is a creature who lives in a place in a city state
and a Greek kind of a city state and and in the same general passage he says a
man who is by nature without a Polis is either more or less than a man and what
he means by that is if a man is superior to the polls doesn't need a polis he is
a god because men need a policy.
And if he is beneath the polls it means he's beneath what it is to be a human
being and that tells you just how potent is this concept of the community for
the Greeks and it emerges in its own way from the Iliad and The Odyssey
Odysseus also was offered an opportunity to live forever when he was shipwrecked
on the island in which the goddess Calypso ruled she fell in love with Odysseus.
This
is the fate of great heroes.
They are heroic and handsome and fast and women love them and she says just stay
with me and you will live forever and all will be well.
And he says well you're a very beautiful girl and I enjoy you a lot but.
I've got to go back to Erica
now why does he have to go back to ethics.
Well he has a wife.
And he whom he loves Penelope and he has a son whom he has barely seen because
he had to go off to Troy.
Almost 20 years ago and to fight that battle and he hasn't been home since.
Those are very powerful pulls that we easily do understand.
But it's also true that he is the king in Ithaca.
And when he returns to Africa he immediately moves into a position of honor and
respect which is a critical part of his own sense of himself of the of what he
needs to be what he wants to be.
And so and I always think it's very very interesting too.
We don't have in American society we don't have an alien an odyssey.
We don't have our own Bible.
But I think Mark Twain's Huck Finn is really very very revealing to see what is
so different about us in the modern times from the Homeric world.
Huck is when things don't go right for Huck what does he do.
He lights out and wants to get away from society.
He wants to go wandering and exploring and on his way almost.
And as an individual rejecting society fleeing for his individualism and that
tradition as you all know what.
How many examples can we think of it of works that.
Really project the greatness of being all by yourself and away from people and
away from society.
That's where good things are.
The Greeks would have thought you were out of your mind they or that you were
some kind of a barbarian.
But that's OK.
People have never known civil society people have never known a world of polio.
Well of course they would do something stupid like that.
But I think that's an interesting contrast.
Let me carry on with this by talking about the views of society which are
characteristic of the two traditions in Western civilization.
What do we see in the Bible when God decides to invent man.
He places him in the garden of Eden the garden of eden contains first of all
just Adam.
And then when God decides for his own reasons
that he needs a companion he invents one other companion.
Eve and where they live his paradise.
One man one woman.
That's all you need.
It's great.
Nothing could ever be so good.
Well what happens they are transgress.
Eve persuade persuaded by them serpent then persuades Adam.
To do what it was forbidden by God.
What is forbidden by God.
It is to eat the fruit of the tree of knowledge because if human beings obtain
knowledge they will be like the gods.
And that is unacceptable.
So when you do that you have to be punished.
What is punishment to be thrown out of Eden to be thrown out of this isolated
condition of perfection by what is perfection.
You don't have to work.
You can eat without doing anything about it.
You don't seem to do much of anything which is fine.
Everything is quiet peaceful.
No problems no action.
That's paradise.
A Greek would go crazy at the thought.
It is a pre social a pre political life.
Life in society which then is what Adam and Eve have to encounter.
They now have to have form villages cities start living among each other and so
on.
That is the punishment for the sin of seeking knowledge of good and evil and
therefore of straining for divinity
man.
The message I think is must know his place which is humble and not close to
divine his hope rests simply with God.
Not with himself when he tries to take things into his own hands and in the
process to contravene the will of God.
Only terrible things can happen to him.
It's very interesting I think that in the 18th century Rousseau.
Who himself seems to me to have been kind of like a poisoned apple in the
history of the human race.
Oddly it revives that biblical view if you think about it.
His view is man was happy and good before the invention of society which society
corrupts man and takes away from him his happiness.
What we need to do is to undo the evils that organized society have done and if
only we removed all of the bad things created by society man would return to his
naturally perfect virtuous self which is of course a major source.
Of.
Individualism which is this great Western Force and the nihilism that I think
inevitably emerges from it.
I think people have in different ways found in Rousseau the root both of a
Nietzsche and nihilism and of Marx and I think there is powerful reason to do so
because you can go in either one of those directions once you start making this
kind of assumption.
For the Greeks on the other hand as I've said political society was essential
for living any kind of a good life.
And the oddest thing you remember Odysseus finds himself.
On the island of the Cyclops those one eyed monsters and what is it about them
that make them so monstrous so inhuman from the perspective of the Homeric
heroes.
And here's the line that Homer writes They live without.
The word is the Greek word is normally which we would translate as laws but
before they become laws they are the customary norms of society.
In other words civilization they live without Nimoy and they wreck not of one
another.
That is to say.
Each family lives by itself.
They have nothing to do with each other.
They do not have a community.
They do not have a society so they are of course.
Sort of prehistoric monsters.
As far as the Greeks are concerned
now.
The Judeo-Christian story as I think of it by the way the word story is a
translation or it means the same thing as the Greek word mythos.
Our word myth a myth in this sense as the Greeks it's just a tale.
It can be true it can be false and so on anyway.
The Judeo Christian story says in the beginning men were innocent.
Innocent was the same as ignorant because knowledge gets in the way of their
innocence and they have solitude.
Living in paradise what destroys their happy permanent condition is the sin of
pride and the consequence of that sin is society corruption.
Pain and death because they knew neither of these needed pain or death while
they were in heathen salvation is available and with it immortality.
But it comes from God.
And it doesn't come in the world in which we live.
But in some other world to be achieved in the future that I think is a very
thumbnail sketch of the Judeo Christian story.
The Greek story is quite different.
War.
Pig is right at the center of it and war itself requires political and social
organization.
There can be fighting without war but there can be no war without an
organization that makes it something more than just plain fighting.
It requires political and social organization.
The search for honor and glory are at the roots of why men fight
and why they do many many other things in their lives.
According to this view the Greeks did have a notion that in a way resembles some
of the things I said about the Judeo-Christian story.
They had a concept called Hubris h y Bahrain is to be translated as something
but among these terms excess arrogance violence.
I think the fullest grasp of it I think might be rendered best by violent
arrogance.
Some notion of being above yourself and thinking yourself more than a man with
the implication that you are approaching some kind of divinity by being more
than a man and acting accordingly which usually requires that you use violence
to achieve what you want and the sort of the standard picture in Greek ethics
runs this way.
A man is.
Granted too much.
He is too well off he is too rich.
He is too strong is too beautiful so much so that he becomes too arrogant and is
ready to step beyond his human condition.
At that point the gods don't like it because like the judeo christian god they
want to have some boundary between the two.
But for them it's very important because it's not the boundary is far from
clear.
So what happens to the man who has too much.
He is afflicted with the hubris which leads him to take the violent action onto
the scene comes to God as arty ATV which might be translated.
Moral blindness in other words he no longer can think straight and so he will do
something dangerous harmful and very ultimately bad for himself.
And when he does whatever it is he is struck by nemesis the goddess of
retribution.
Well of course the most famous Greek case I think of these things is in
Sophocles play Oedipus the King which illustrates that perfectly well.
Oedipus is a brilliant man.
He achieves the kingship of his city because of his extraordinarily
extraordinary intelligence and he is a very good man.
He is king.
Don't imagine that he is a despot.
Anything but the people love him.
He saved the city thanks to his brilliance and his goodwill.
However after a while he comes to be too satisfied too comfortable with his own
brilliance.
And when another threat comes to the city he is confident that he can solve the
problem again for his people.
His worn by the gods through seers and by men of wisdom saying Don't don't don't
investigate this question too far you might be making a mistake.
He won't listen.
He pulls ahead and he discovers in the process the terrible terrible truth which
is that by accident by coincidence not by intent but that as a young man he
killed his father and subsequently married his mother.
And this most horrible of combinations of facts drives him and he's already
suffered from the hubris and the RTA and the retribution is terrible in his what
to say and his madness.
When he discovers that he tears out his own eyes and blinds himself and of
course now for the rest of his life he must just go about as a kind of a beggar.
Having been this form a tremendously great king.
So these are examples of what happens in Greek ethics later on if you are guilty
of this characteristic.
On the other hand when he even Oedipus himself when he understands and he
relents and in a sense he apologizes for what he's done.
But more importantly he ceases of course to be powerful and to act in that way.
Wisdom comes to him.
He understands.
He has acted in moderately.
That is the critical concept.
Moderation is this wonderfully great important thing for the Greeks.
You must act in moderation.
Don't be.
They don't ask you to just be humble and throw yourself on the ground and
consider yourself as nothing compared to the God or the gods.
Be a man be proud of what you should be proud of.
But don't go beyond limit of what is human because if you do terrible things
will come.
Seek fame.
We all want that.
And I'll say more about that.
But you can't push it too far.
There has to be some kind of reasonable human limit to what you do.
So here is this problem.
It's typically Greek problem where there is a contradiction that you've got to
live with.
You can't resolve you as if you want to seek the fullness of a human experience.
You have to try to be the best possible man the greatest possible man to compete
successfully against others and to achieve fame glory and recognition for what
you've achieved.
But if you push it too far.
You will anger the gods and something terrible will happen to you.
So.
It seems to me that Western civilization ever since has been a composite of
these two traditions but there is no way to put them together.
And so Western civilization is an ambiguous society with a war always ranging
within the soul of Western civilization.
And it's never perfectly clear which of the two approaches to life.
Is the better one.
I don't know whether any of you have ever thought about this and anything like
this way but if you contemplate your own
way of thinking about what you what are you supposed to be doing with your life
I think you'll find some combination if you're a sort of typical but that
combination doesn't ever have to be 50/50 and I'm sure it very rarely is more
typically one aspect of the culture dominates rather than the other.
But the shifts in place and time and in many I would say throughout most human
beings there is a consciousness of both.
They both have some attraction and one has to grapple with them.
So they're part of you wants to become the greatest whatever it is that you want
to become.
And you wouldn't be here if you weren't very competitive and very eager to come
out first
devoted to retain your own version of that kind of thing and yet.
It's very easy to say to you that's not a good thing to do.
That's what you should try to do is to be humble.
You should be like what Jesus suggests in the Sermon on the mount.
There's your soul is in deep danger if you indeed continue to lead the life that
you have mainly been leading up to now.
And those two things are in conflict where I don't give you ever go to church
that is no longer confined to a religious organization.
Those are key parts float around in Western civilization all the time.
There are aspects of.
Demand for performance at the highest level.
At the same time as there's a great deal of blaming people for pursuing such
things instead of humility that's Western civilization friends and the Greeks
are at the root of the whole thing.
So now let me turn to my next topic which is to leave the world of Homer behind
us and to begin to tell the story of how it was that the characteristic unit of
Greek civilization the Poles came into being out of the dark ages.
We've said a little bit about the let me say a little bit first of all about the
way scholars have categorized.
The history of Greece typically we speak of the bronze it Bronze Age the Meissen
the period and so on followed by the Dark Ages.
But after that you start having refined terms which derive actually excuse me
from the world of the history of art.
And that is because in the dark ages we don't have any writing.
So if you want to designate anything it has to be by.
Tangible things like pottery particularly painted pottery when you have it
because it's easier to categorize and it's from that that most of our terms show
up.
So for instance you will see references to words like proto geometric post and
they'll be sort of post my in then proto geometric.
These would be the very earliest kinds of pots that have geometric designs on
them.
Then comes the geometric period and the Orientalism period all of these refer to
pottery styles but there is then next come to a larger period which is referred
to as the Archaic Period
archaic Visa V.
The classical period which is this big start was the central subject of people's
interest in the Greeks to begin with and later on they studied its surrounding
periods in this archaic period is roughly speaking about 750 B.C. to 500 B.C.
why this period as a unit what makes it a unit.
Well it's around 750 a great number of the changes that move the Greeks away
from the dark age kind of society to the full scale Poles begin.
And five hundred.
Because really I would have said if you were being more a little bit more
precise you would say something like.
Well no even 500 isn't really bad because if you think about the Persian Wars as
being the breaking point before the Persian Wars you're in the archaic period
after the Persian Wars you're in the classical period.
Well the Persian Wars begin in four ninety nine B.C. when my latest starts the
Ionian rebellion.
So that's really I think the reason for the dating
during this archaic periods some of the things that happen are these the
isolation of the Greek towns in the dark age gives way increasingly to contact
with the East and the South.
When I say the South I really mean Egypt and all around the eastern Aegean Sea
the rise of the poles is based upon critical economic military social and
political changes all of which produce a world that's really strikingly
different from the one that was just before
I suppose the first apparently historical event that we know something about is
the.
The first Olympic Games which according to Greek tradition were held in 776 B.C.
the precision of that of course is not to be taken seriously but it gives you a
general idea of when we are talking about
and the fact this is what's interesting about that is that the Olympic games
like all of the pan hellenic games it was the first of the pan hellenic games
was not a local event just for one policy and maybe for a couple it was one to
which all the people who thought of themselves as Helen's which we would call
Greeks took part in.
So that meant the concept that there is something that all of us are have in
common that make us all hellions now exists.
It's not there.
In Homer.
So that's one thing then literacy returns to the Greek world.
It is as I told you before not a development of the Meissen in the script
which we saw but rather a new writing system a true alphabet most of the symbols
were borrowed from a kind of of a Semitic language and a Semitic alphabet that
came from finished.
I would have guessed or someplace near it.
I think I mentioned to you that the Greeks.
Improved upon it made it a true alphabet by taking some signs that they didn't
need for their own language and turning them into vowel signs.
You know if you read a well good example of that kind of a Semitic script is
Hebrew.
If you read the Biblical Hebrew you have to supply the vowels yourself.
You have to know where the vowels are supposed to go.
But from here.
And that makes it harder to learn how to read.
Well when you have the vowel sounds it's easier and the Greeks made that
contribution in one of Plato's lesser known dialogues.
He makes a statement the following statement which I think shows both the
typical arrogance of the Greeks and also says something true.
He says the Greeks never invented anything but everything they borrowed they
improved upon.
I think they probably also invented a few things but it was very very
characteristic of the Greeks to borrow from the cultures they encountered and to
adapt them to make them more useful for their own purposes.
And nothing could be clearer than that the alphabet is an example of that
henceforth we will see writing in Greece now very very little of it.
And of course what we have is confined to things that are not perishable.
These would have been inscriptions either on pottery which the earliest ones are
or on stone but otherwise I'm sure there was writing on perishable material
wooden plaques.
Probably not yet paper but but these would have been destroyed.
So what we have is on the pottery.
We know that the Greeks established the first the first colony of which we know
the Greeks that the Greeks did establish it was in the Bay of Naples on the
island of escape.
They established a colony somewhere in the 7 fifties and soon afterwards there
is a colony established on the east coast of Sicily.
At what we call Syracuse now and a rash of others so that the Greeks are in the
seven fifties engaged in spreading themselves from the mainland of Greece and
from the Aegean in general even so far out west as Italy and Sicily and soon we
know they are in touch with just about every place in the Mediterranean Sea in
the same period.
There is clear cut unmistakable Oriental influence on Greek pottery and other
things that they make.
What Oriental that means mainly the Tigris and Euphrates Mesopotamia Syria all
those older civilizations and more and much more advanced civilizations and the
Greek Greeks are in touch with them again and they borrow stylised copy styles
maybe they in the early days maybe they used some of the craftsmen from out
there or maybe they just their own craftsmen picked it up.
However that may be no question about it.
Contact interaction influence most of the influence I suspect was going one way
in those days from the more advanced civilizations of the east to the Greeks the
Greeks are doing a lot of learning borrowing and adopting
and of course this is the period in which the Homeric epics are finally written
down now that there is writing and that gives them I think even greater impact
on the Greek world in the future all of these things are happening about the
same time as there is a also happening a major fundamental change in farming.
Commerce and warfare.
Which will have very significant political consequences as well.
But I want to postpone that story for a little while
let me then just turn to this phenomenon that is the polls
the polls the word poll this appears in Homer as early as Homer.
When it means something different from what it means throughout most of Greek
history it just means a physical place and what it real appears to be is the
citadel the fortress that was the center of the towns that grew up after the
Bronze Age after the collapse of the Meissen mean world.
So that's how it is in Homer later definitions however will be expansive and
broad and as you go further and deeper into Greek history the claims become
greater and greater.
Aristotle in his politics of course tells us the most on this subject and often
he is our source of information but one thing is clear and pretty early.
The Polis is not merely a city state in the same way as let us say the
Mesopotamian city states of the third millennium B.C. were places like or or
Kish towns that we know back there those places were simply the place where the
king or the emperor ruled the place where the main gods Palace was the place
where the bureaucrats were to do their business.
That's that's what it was.
No more than that.
But immediately very early you start hearing the Greeks talk about the palace in
terms that are more in your mind than in in your chuch
6th century Greek poet named Elsie is wrote.
Not houses finally roofed or the stone of walls well-built built.
No not canals or dockyards make the Poles but men able to use their opportunity
and to get into the 5th century late in the fifth century facilities and as
history has one of his.
Generals speak to his men and say men are the poets.
So we need to straighten out for ourselves what does that mean.
Does that mean that the place where these people live is not the polls.
Is it only men.
Well we'll come back to that let me read you something as we move to the fullest
claims that will be made for the role of the polis Aristotle in the politics.
He says this as man is the best of the animals when perfected so he is the worst
of all when he is divided away from law and justice but he tells us human
justice can be found only in the polls because he says Man is by nature a
politic con Zo on an animal of the polls and as I told you a man who is without
a pulse by nature is above or below the category of man.
Because man alone has the faculty of speech and the ability to distinguish good
from bad and right from wrong.
While he is born with weapons for the use of wisdom and virtue he may use them
for the opposite ends.
Therefore when he is without virtue man is the most savage of animals justice on
the other hand is an element of the polls the administration of justice which
means deciding what is just is the regulation of the partnership which is the
polls man can't live without the polls.
Justice exists only in the polls.
The polls is something more than a place.
It's more than the walls it's more than the ships is it is some kind of a thing
that is spiritual.
It seems to me
but about the size of this thing.
Oh no maybe Becca there's something else I wanted to say to indicate this
notion.
Of men being the polls as opposed to anything tangible.
When the Persians conquer the Greek cities of Asia Minor when they came to the
coastal city of Fossey.
The folks the four seasons had a choice.
Of either giving bread and water to the great king and becoming subjects of the
Persians.
All would have meant what they would have had to pay taxes and do military
service for the king.
He didn't go about killing people and conquer.
They chose instead to take their city which is to say all the people in the city
put them on ships sail to the far west.
And organize a new city out there.
And in fact they landed on the Riviera in France and did pretty well for
themselves afterwards.
But that's a beautiful example.
They thought they had taken their polos with them because they had moved the
entire city there during the Persian Wars.
When Mr. Cleese is trying to convince his fellow Greeks to stay and fight at
Selma's but they are reluctant to do so she says OK if you won't stay and fight
it sounds well all our men are already located on our ships.
We will take these ships sail them away to Italy and settle in Athens in Italy.
Well the Spartans take them very seriously and they say OK we'll stay and fight
at soundness so such a concept was a possibility.
It's not the whole story though.
Let me turn to the question of the physical.
Picture that you ought to have of a pulse.
Remember there is that Citadel standing on a high hill the Acropolis as it's
called.
The Poles are high.
There is surrounding farmland
going as far.
Typically as there is either a natural or an artificial frontier typically a
mountain range will be the boundary between the area of two poles or a stretch
of water because Greece has to see winding through it everywhere.
But when that's not true then there is a typical sort of modern frontier a a
land bridge which then a line is a theoretical line is drawn through it.
And on one side is one city and the other side knows it is a wonderful
archeological discovery of a boundary stone up in the near Athens which on which
is written on one side.
This is Athens.
It is not Negara.
On the other side it says this is Negara.
It is not Athens.
So there is that kind of a boundary as well.
And.
That is a place where trouble is likely to emerge.
Greeks will say once the police are in place they will spend a great deal of
time fighting each other.
A normal reason for fighting is a dispute about a piece of land that is more or
less on the boundary between them.
And so that's one aspect of their world.
What about how big are these things.
Answer from the 20th century America.
Very small.
I think the word tiny might be justified.
We start with the most abnormal of them in this respect.
The largest Polis of which we know it's Athens.
Unlike many police Athens had been successful in gaining the city of Athens
itself had been successful in gaining control of the whole region which had
dominated the region of Attica so that anybody by the time history dawns anybody
who lives in the peninsula that is Attica is an Athenian even if he lives in a
village or a good sized town 60 miles away.
He is still an Athenian he can be a citizen of his community he can be a
marathon in but he is also and more primarily he is an Athenian.
Now Atika.
Was is in fact approximately a thousand square miles which I'm told is about the
size of Rhode Island.
And that's the biggest Polis of which we know.
There are well over a thousand police.
Some people want to push the number at its height up to maybe fifteen hundred
but doesn't matter.
You're talking about lots and lots of what is the typical
size of them.
What is the typical population of them.
Well Aristotle and Plato both sort of theoreticians of the polis each had an
idea what's the right size for the perfect post.
Aristotle said the right size is a place where.
All of the citizens by which he meant male adult citizens could come to a
central place and hear a speaker and that number comes out to be about 5000 male
adults Plato.
Being a mathematician as Aristotle was not decided that the perfect place would
have five thousand and forty citizens why five thousand and forty.
You may ask do we have any mathematicians among us who will give me a quick
answer to that
saying in.
I don't even know what that means.
That's how good a mathematician I am.
Tell me does it mean the same thing as it has the greatest number of.
Numbers that go into it equally.
That's the answer I heard that all right.
Okay.
Yeah.
Simpson.
All right enough of this mathematical folderol.
As you can see I don't understand but look here's the point.
We're talking about five thousand adult males.
That's the ideal polis as far as these guys are concerned.
Athens was not the ideal place.
It was big.
How many men did it have in its fullest blown somewhere between 40 and 50000.
It's impossible to have a better guess than that.
Then if you want to say how many human beings lived in Attica when the greatest
number did we are speaking about something between a quarter of a million and
three hundred sounds but you have to understand just from what I've already told
you this is extraordinarily large and I think you must realize that most polls
if you're thinking about a thousand or more polls would have been well under
five thousand adult male citizens so I would just wanted to give you an idea of
just how small most of these places are as well as indicating sharp departures.
OK.
Now the polls from the beginning and it never stopped being that what I'm about
to say chiefly agricultural communities
most of the people and I think it's reasonable to guess that a very high
majority of the people would be living on farms engaged in farming feeding
themselves and the rest of the community.
Unlike the ancient near eastern cities these towns do not grow up around a
temple or a market place.
Confluence of rivers as they do in medieval Europe.
No they grow up like the Athenian does right smack in the middle of a plane
which is a good place for farming with a great high Acropolis available even the
characteristic thing in a poll is the Agora the marketplace which is also
becomes the civic center of these towns.
Even these grew up later than the polls they show up a century or more typically
after.
We know that there's a polis there and the Agora comes about in a gradual way.
I think you should never imagine in these real old policies that got things
started that somebody said let's have a pollers
things just happen.
They just grew up one nice way that if you think here Athens is helpful.
How many of you ever been to Athens resident Yeah.
And the rest of you when you go on the north shore north slope of the Acropolis
beyond the agora.
There is the the area of Athens known as the plaque.
It's the oldest inhabited area in Athens and there you will find that unlike the
more modern Athens in which streets laid out at 90 degrees angles perfectly.
It's a mess.
I mean the streets whined around and.
And that's because the original streets were followed the way the cattle did
their wandering looking for food and then they that became the roads.
So you have to.
I want to stress the sense of natural development not some kind of a central
authority making a decision about anything.
It is also pretty clear that for some time after the foundation of the poles
there were no city walls.
These were not defended your your farmland was not defended.
If you had a house outside the Acropolis as you would it was not defended what
happened.
If the town was attacked invaded everybody who could ran up to the Acropolis to
defend himself.
So that's how things were in the elementary phase.
Now there are Greek traditions that are taken seriously by the Greeks that
suggest that kings ruled these cities from the beginning and they have lists of
kings with their names and sometimes with stories attached to them.
And I think myself that there were people who had the title Barcelona's.
And they were noblemen and that they had some kind of a position of influence
and authority in the state.
But as I think we have seen already.
They were not kings in the oriental sense and
once we have a palace it looks as though we don't have kings any longer in any
shape manner or form.
What.
Kind of regime that emerges alongside the polos is an aristocratic republic in
which the noblemen have influence and power within the community by tradition
and they are plural.
There was not one real king there are there is typically a council of
aristocrats that is the outfit that counts
he said whom I have not mentioned to you before.
A poet who we think to have lived around 700 B.C. very early in the history of
the palace
wrote one of his poems called the works and days is advice to farmers on how to
live but it also contains a story in which he talks about himself and the quarry
has with his brother over who inherits what from the father and he claims he's
been cheated out of his inheritance inheritance because his brother bribed the
judges.
Well who are these judges.
He calls them busty lace kings.
These would have been these aristocratic figures who we know in the earliest
days of the polls.
They were the judicial authority basing that on their claim to divine descent on
their certainly noble descent and on the fact that the nobility had a monopoly
of knowledge about what the traditions of the community are.
So but he said complains about the it calls them bribe swallowing postulates
crooked ones plural plural kings as in Homer.
It's also interesting Athens has a very clear tradition of thinking they had
kings and I think very telling is the story they said they give us about how
kingship came to an end in Athens.
I mean I just want to let me start by.
Contrasting it with what I think is fairly typical.
The Romans also had kings.
I think they had probably real kings just before the emergence of their republic
and that of kingship came to an end according to the Romans story.
And the Republic succeeded it when one of the kings the last one talked Quintus
superbugs to purpose and that means arrogant
corneas misbehaved most seriously by raping the daughter of a nobleman Lucrecia
that caused the rebellion and they overthrew the Kings and thereafter the word
King was a dirty word in Roman history.
The best example is when Julius Caesar has made himself master of Rome but he's
still behaving as though the Republic exists.
People either who want to embarrass him.
Well yes I think people want to embarrass and send around the story.
Caesar is wants to make himself king.
The word for king in Latin is Rex.
And so he he he's tried to diffuse that with a pun by saying known some Rex said
Kaiser I'm not Rex I'm not King I'm not Rex my name is Caesar.
Well.
In fact he pretty well was ready to turn himself into a king but he wouldn't use
that word.
He wouldn't use that word because it had such a terrible smell.
Kings were despots dictators rapists they were not you didn't want to be one.
Well.
Look at the story of the Athenians.
Tell
there was this king of Athens coldness was his name.
They were the Athenians were invaded by an army from the outside.
Congress led his forces out against them.
He fought brilliantly and bravely and drove the enemy from the field.
In the course of the battle he himself was killed.
The Athenians loved and respected him so much that they gave him the almost
unheard of honor of burying him right on the spot where he fell in the field and
thereafter his name was always followed with glory admiration and devotion.
Well what kind of a story is that.
How do you get rid of a kingdom.
Why would you get rid of King.
Oh I forgot to tell you the.
Why did they get rid of the king because they thought they could never have
another one so good so why try.
Give me a break.
No I think somebody had to make up a story but their memory of Kings was not of
a tar corneas.
It was not of a brutal despotic ruler because they didn't have any such thing.
We don't know how the change came about or if some people question if they ever
really did have kings.
But the picture I want you to have is that's not the tradition.
The tradition is aristocracy.
That's what we connect with the Poles and of course it was all natural because
it also fit into the world of the Iliad The Odyssey which they were accustomed
to think about.
I think that's a good place to start.
Next time I will take up the story of the expansion of the world of the colors
which takes the form of colonization.